in 1972 the chess world witnessed
something very special it was this round
sixth game of the World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
Boris Spassky special for many reasons
to name a few
Fischer for only the third time in
series play began with c4 and regarding
the game itself it's maybe best
described in the words of international
master Anthony Sadie who said quote it
was like a symphony of Placid beauty end
quote and not to be overlooked was a
wonderful act of sportsmanship by Boris
Spassky who after the game stood up and
applauded Fischer for the masterful game
he just played this is that game so
Fischer opening up with C for the
English opening but what will soon see
is that it transposes into a Queens
gambit declined and that could be
denoted by these group of pawns right
here after Knight f6 Knight c3 soon
enough we enter the tartakower variation
with this move 7 b6 this h6 move is just
throwing question of the bishop there's
not really going to be any way to
exploit this type of a weakness against
the black King side it's more long-term
flight Square for that King and you'll
note that after this b6 advance it's
only at this point does Fischer decide
to release the tension between these two
pawns only after this bishop only after
the black has spent a move in creating a
new door for this Bishop if white is to
capture maybe prior to that b6 move then
the bishop can make use of this classic
diagonal but again only after that b6
advance does white now clarified the
structure in the center capturing on d5
we do have a series of exchanges and
after the smoke clears this is the pawn
structure we're now dealt with rooks e1
logical enough applying pressure to this
c7 pon Bishop e6 a curious move one may
think why not just play to beasts
and b6 was played for a purpose but
black isn't going forward with the
Bishop e6 move if you do a quick
comparison between this e six square and
B seven square some of the differences
may include well from b7 it's
unprotected be six it's not and
additionally the bishop might want to
later make use of let's say f5 or even
harass the knight by playing to g4 so
now Queen a4 and one of the interesting
things in my opinion with this game is
how the White Queen makes use of the
whole chessboard or really maybe better
stated wherever she is that's where the
ensuing play will take place so right
now the stuff is happening on the Queen
side after this Queen a4 move again
still looking to do something against
this c7 pawn black presses forward
challenging that d4 point of whites
Queen a3 this is a bit of an
uncomfortable pin and a third piece is
now hitting that c5 pawn rook pawn and
Queen it needs it needs additional
support rook c8 is decided on and now
more development by white that's one
step closer to being fully developed and
why not play to b5 in some sense you're
just boxing out that knight on b8 a6 is
for the moment not yet a threat since
this rook is unprotected so there's no
need to react to a threat that's not
there instead we just have more
clarification in the center with details
see B take C and the resulting structure
is the hanging pawn structure so ideally
white would like to have both rooks on
the C and D file applying pressure to
these guys white castles fully developed
and now only after rook a7 in the Queen
now defending that rook does white react
with the Bishop e2 just tucking it away
and just taking a snapshot of this
position right here
it's just seems so smooth right now
the night on a classic square f3 the
bishop tucked away and eat to a rook
very well placed soon enough the F rook
one would think is going to be placed to
the d1 square black being still in this
slightly awkward pin okay yes it's
protected right here but on the black
end look at the disjointed nature
between these rooks right here and the
Knights still on its home square and
isolated pawn on a6
after just these 17 moves okay it's a
pretty decent amount of moves but the
differences between both sides I think
is a great one and soon enough what
we'll see is an additional imbalance
taking place as it stands right now it's
just with regard to the pawn structure
this hanging pawn structure so more
development for for black fully
developed at this point but again not so
harmonious Knight d4 making use of this
pin this Knight is now providing a
disconnect between the Queen and rook so
a very timely Knight d4 is going to
grant this Nitra bishop exchange so the
Queen backs up getting out of the pin
and just for the one moment well just
taking that Bishop right away and after
the recapture we have now one strike in
the center that really is going to turn
the tables these ponds right here the
furthest advanced ones this pawn duo on
the fifth rank is challenged with e4 and
something needs to be done and what
black tries is just pressing forward
which is typical if you do have the
knight you want to try and keep things
closed that d4 move is a step in that
direction it's also a passed pawn but as
will soon see this cupon really could
just never get going and is no serious
threat to white whatsoever additionally
with that advance we now looking a bit
more closely at the pawn structure
recognize that we have a 4-3 majority
in favor in tipping in White's favor on
the Kings side now that said that's not
to say you're supposed to throw up all
of your pawns in this direction it's
more commonly seen that just these F the
F pond and epon for white will be the
ones to press forward and try and induce
some weakness against the black side and
the G and H pawns will just stay back
and act as the shield for that white
King so that's exactly what we see F for
these pawns get rolling Queenie seven
and now II five right here this is now a
static point for black this pawn is
immobile and will soon be pinpointed so
rook to b8 it wasn't really needed
anymore to watch over that c5 square so
now coming back to this b file to exert
pressure on b2 Bishop c4 get
repositioning time at this point placing
this pawn and a pin and looking forward
to an f5 advance where this pond is just
going to strike at a six black gets out
of that and now the Queen's swinging
over again really dictating where the
play will take place in the game so
making use of this whole third rank
right here sweeping from a3 2 H 3 and
now pinpointing that east 6 pawn for a
second time Knight f8 retreat to defend
a6 and now something as simple as b3
makes these rooks look absolutely
ridiculous because there's nothing
that's now going to take place on the
Queen side you can forget about it just
this Bishop and two pawns alone this is
one one thing that I like to do my own
games is just recognize how a particular
grouping of pieces can negate an
opponent's group of pieces and right now
it's just these three highlighted white
pieces negating these three right here
or in other words you could view it as
like a 5 on 5 5 points negating 11
points and there's a on the flip side of
things there's going to now be
a group of let's say these two rooks and
queen and even the bishop that are
influencing the Kings side this bishop
right here really being a multi-purpose
piece in some sense locking down on the
Queen side and still exerting pressure
on that King side so 85 looking to get
in this advance right here looking to
maybe peel up in that a file but things
happen too quickly on the Kings side
f5 something needing to be done about
maybe capturing on e6 or even pressing
forward one more step to f6 and that
King will be in some serious hot water
if that's allowed so the pawn is
captured and it's the rook on F that
recaptures so that this rook can soon
contribute doubling on the F file Knight
h6 r h7 looking to reposition to that g5
square white doubles the Queen backs up
to d8 Queen g3 allows this pot to press
forward to h4 and what we basically see
now is that move played and look at this
sad night right here it's just
completely restricted and this bishop is
incredibly dominant the the differences
between this bishop and Knight are just
enormous this Bishop is just way too
powerful as we will soon see in the
resulting final position so there's not
really a whole lot unfortunately for
black to be done right here these rooks
are just helpless to really doing
anything this is the only completely
open file and white controls it it
really cannot be contested whatsoever so
pressing forward with e6 rook c7
defending this c5 pawn queen a seven
repositioning for white and
unfortunately for black for pretty much
the duration of the game just can do
nothing more than just shuffle the Queen
on these d8 and e 8 squares so basically
emphasizing at this point is white you
know I black has nothing to do just a 4
doesn't even
the possibility for black to play a four
and create some opening on the Queen
side so Queen d8 rook f2 slightly I
guess curious move maybe in some sense
it's saying you know what there's
nothing that you could even do maybe
just emphasizing the fact that the black
has again nothing or maybe also another
way to view it is it's wanting to play
to f3 so that after this Queen d8 move
White has Bishop d3 and this pun can now
not be taken white may be wanting this
particular sequence to come about so
that Bishop d3 could be played and
there's not going to now be rook takes
pawn if the Queen was still on e8 this
would now be available after the Bishop
d3 move but as it stands after Queen d8
white now focuses the attention on this
diagonal right here and soon enough we
have a tactical shot coming into play
here a nice battery the threat now being
ripped to f8 which is going to be deadly
for example if rook takes e6 we would
just have rook check Knight takes rook
rook takes Knight removing the defender
of h7 Queen takes her up Queen h7 and
that's game over
so rook takes pawn is not played instead
what is tried is just a knight move to
f6 but Fischer just rips the position
right open grabbing that Knight
recapture a couple times on f6 and King
to g8 this is a hopeless position for
white what is tried is just King g8 but
after Bishop c4 the king is just having
to get off of this diagonal so that this
rook maybe has the possibility to move
moving it now is going to allow the pun
to just press forward one step closer to
queening as well as having a discovered
check against the king so the King goes
back to the corner but after Queen to f4
black could do nothing more than resign
right here the threats are just way too
much we have the possibilities for rook
to f8 winning the Queen rook takes h6
check
Queen takes h6 check there's not really
a whole lot black can do just to show
one variation if the King is to let's
say come back over to g8 we could have
Queen takes h6 and with now the threat
of rook g6 check and pawn push there's
really not really a whole lot black and
dude just kind of making a passing move
if route b7 we could have this check
rook Blanko sh discovered check and what
to do the Queen Esther block you could
pick your favorite way to mate at this
point promotion or just capturing right
here however you slice it black is beat
from this position after Fisher's 41st
move Queen to f4 so in this sort of
video it's it's really my hope that it
acts as a great example of how the whole
chessboard can be made use of and how
seemingly simple moves can translate
into a significant advantage and of how
competitors of this great game can or
really should carry themselves in a
similar way as Boris Spassky did in
defeat